[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
هذا الفيديو
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه تصف الهجمات في
بريانيسك الحدوديه بالمفبركه وبوتين
يعتبرها ارهابا اوكرانيا
لقاء مقتضى بين بلينك ولابروف هو الاول
منذ الحرب في قمه العشرين والبيان الختمي
للقمه لم يتبنى موقفا بشان اوكرانيا
وتطالب واشنطن بوقف تسليح الجزيره
هنا في مخيم الهول في الحسكه نسخه متجدده
عن تنظيم داعش اصغر العربيه تكشف دوره
نساء داعش بمخيم الهول في تنسيق عمليات
القتل والتعذيب لالزام القاطنين فيه بحكم
التنظيم
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
هجوم جديد من نوعه شهدته اليوم مقاطعه
بريانيسك الروسيه الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا
هجوم تبادل فيه الطرفان الروسي والاوكراني
المجموعه التي اغتالت ابنه المفكر الروسي
المقرب من الكريم
تبنت الهجمات في بريانيس ونشرت مقطعا
مصورا لعناصرها داخل المقاطعه وهم يرفعون
شعار الجيش الاوكراني
المخابرات الاوكرانيه من جهتها قالت ان
الهجوم نفذه معارضون من الداخل ضد نظام
الرئيس بوتين ويريدون القضاء عليه في حين
قال مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل
بودالياك ان الهجوم مفبرك ومزيف
الرئيس الروسي بلاديمير بوتين وصف الهجوم
على بريانس الحدوديه بالارهابي وقال خلال
كلمه له ان المسلحين اطلقوا النار رغم
علمهم بوجود مدنيين واطفال فلكيكه
اليوم نفذوا هجوما ارهابيا اخر نفذوا
جريمه اخرى على منطقه حدوديه وفتحوا النار
على مدنيين رغم رؤيتهم بان السياره مدنيه
ويجلس فيها مدنيون واطفاله هؤلاء الاشخاص
اخذوا على عاتقهم مهمه انتزاع ذاكرتنا
وتاريخنا وعاداتنا وحتى لغتنا
من موسكو لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم اليه مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا وسهلا بك
اخر المعلومات المتعلقه بملابسات ومالات
هذا الهجوم في بريانيسك وهل توضحت فعاليه
بالنسبه الى موسكو الجهه المنفذه
مرحبا طالب بعض التحيه لنبدا مباشره مع
العاجل منذ دقائق خرجت هيئه الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي وتحدثت في اخر بيان لها
حول ما حدث فيبريانس تتحدث عن المنطقه
هناك
بكاملها تحت السيطره القوات الحكوميه
الروسيه تتحدث ايضا عن بدء عمليه تفتيش
واسعه في تلك المنطقه والوقوف على كل
التفاصيل بالاضافه الى ذكرها بانها عثرت
على العديد من المواد المتفجره والعبوات
في تلك المناطق ويتم العمل على يعني
تعطيلها من قبل لجان مختصه طالب طبعا اخر
الاحصائيات تتحدث عن مقتل شخص كان يقود
سياره واصابه طفل يبلغ من العمر 11 عاما
بعد اطلاق النار عليهما عند استقلاله مالي
سياره في تلك المنطقه طبعا طالب هذا هذه
ليست المره الاولى التي تتعرض فيها مناطق
حدوديه روسيه لضربات اوكرانيه لكن الفارقه
الوحيد اليوم ان هذه المناطق تعرضت لدخول
عناصر تابعوني للقوات الاوكرانيه حسب
الروايه الروسيه او مرتبطين بهم بشكل
مباشر طبعا هذه العناصر قامت بتنفيذ هذه
المهمه دار الحديث بين الجدل وبين الحقيقه
واختلاف طبعا نقل الصوره بسبب التعتيم
الواضح على هذا الموضوع باحتجاز بعض
الرهائن دار الحديث عن اعداد كبيره ومن ثم
طبعا تم الحديث رسميا على ان هذه الاعداد
قد تصل الى سته اشخاص لكن المنطقه التي
دار الجدل عليها مسافتها تصل الى 15 كيلو
مترا ما يعني حسب قراءه القراء السياسيين
والعسكريين في البلاد بان عشرات الاشخاص
شاركوا في هذا الهجوم طبعا هي
الجواب يعني السؤال يسال يعني السؤال
التلقائي عبد الجواد انه كيف تمكنت هذه
المجموعات من الدخول الى هذه المنطقه
الروسيه والى اي مدى هذا يشكل اختراق
وسابقه خطيره بالنسبه الى الروس
سؤالك في محله طالب طبعا هذا السؤال قراته
مرات عده طرحته العديد من الوسائل طرحه
العديد من رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هو حديث الشعب والناس كيف لمنطقه حدوديه
مجاوره لمناطق ساخنه واكثرها ان يتسلل
منها هذا العدد الكبير نحو الاراضي
الروسيه حتى هذه اللحظه رسميه لا يوجد اي
رده فعل واي جواب حول هذا الموضوع لكن
طالب يعني خلال تواجد كاميرا العربيه في
تلك المناطق خلال العام الماضي هذا الشريط
الحدودي هو كبير يعني كما تم ملاحظته
والوقوف عليه لا يمكن ضبط كافه المعايير
بالرغم من وجود عدد كبير من الكاميرات من
الحساسات التي تعمل بشكل تلقائي وبشكل
اوتوماتيكي عند وجود يعني اي قوات تتقدم
او اي اشخاص يمرون عبر هذا الشريط الحدودي
يعني اذكر بشكل واضح عندما اقتربت من هذا
الشريط خلال عملي في تلك المنطقه عملت
هناك طبعا كافه يعني اجهزه الانذار التي
تنذر وتتحدث عن وجود اشخاص في تلك المنطقه
لذلك طبعا هو سؤال حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد
جواب له لا رسميا ولا على الصعيد ساكتفي
بهذا القدر من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الجواد
وفي التطورات الميدانيه ايضا نشرت مجموعه
فاغنر مقطعا مصورا لقواتها داخل مركز
مدينه بعد قتال عنيف مستمر منذ اسابيع
وقال مؤسس المجموعه
[موسيقى]
ومع استمرار القتال العنيف في مدينه باخمت
الاوكرانيه تزداد اعداد جنود الاوكرانيين
الجرحى في خط المواجهه مع سعى الكرملي
للاستيلاء على المدينه منذ شهور من قبضه
الجيش الاوكراني
من دوناتس لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الي مراسل العربيه رائد اولا
يعني قائد مجموعه نشر فيديوهات له من مركز
مدينه
هل يمكن تاكيد ذلك ان قوات فاجنر بمعنى
القوات الروسيه
سيطرت على وسط المدينه ام لا يعني هذه
المعلومات حتى الساعه تظل الى حد ما غامضه
طالب مساء الخير بالفعل معارك ضاريه
ومحتدمه في هذه المدينه وهي الاكثر سخونه
بكل المعارك رغم ان المعارك مستمره في
محور خارك وفي دانيسكو وفي مارينكا
وفيافديفكا وعمليات عسكريه كبيره هناك
امدادات عسكريه بشريه بالجنود للمنطقه هنا
في دمباس وخاصه في دانيت لكن هذا الفيديو
الذي اظهره يعني نشره مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر
بروجين على صفحته على تيليجرام يشير الى
ان
رجاله ما زالوا في وسط المدينه او وصلوا
الى وسط المدينه ربما بالامس كنا نتحدث عن
ان القوات الروسيه وقوات فاجنر تبعد اقل
من كيلومترين عن قلب المدينه ربما تقدموا
اكثر لان تصريحاته كانت تقول بانهم تقريبا
وسط المدينه او عمليا يعني لانه يجزم بانه
هو هذا مركز المدينه او وسط المدينه ما
زالت المعارك محتدمه قال نفسه يوم امس بان
القوات الاوكرانيه
ارسلت تعزيزات وامدادات عسكريه بشريه
وبالاليات ايضا بعشرات الالاف الجانب
الاوكراني ايضا رغم اقراره بصعوبه الوضع
في باقمه لكنه يشير الى تمسكه ومقاومته
العنيفه في هذه المدينه القوات الروسيه
دخلت بالفعل من ثلاث نواحي كما اسلفنا
دائما طالب من الشمال والجنوب والشرق
دخلوا عده كيلومترات ويسيطرون على احياء
سكنيه ذات الطوابق الخمسه ويتقدمون متر
تلو المتر او مبنى تلو المبنى المدينه
اصلا صغيره وهي شكلها ياتي على يعني طولي
وليس عرضي او دائري فهي اذا تقدموا من
الناحيه الشرقيه حيث المصانع والمعامل
التي ما زالت المعارك ضاريه فانهم سيبعدون
عن مركز المدينه اذا دخلوا ثلاثه اربعه
كيلومترات سيكونون يعني بعيدون بعيدين عن
المدينه عده كيلو متر او اثنين فقط فمن
الطبيعي اذا حصل تقدم او انسحاب بسيط
للقوات الاوكرانيه فانهم يكونون قد وصلوا
الى عمق المدينه هل انت عندما تتابع يعني
كل الاخبار عن بخموت ولا شيء سوى بخموت هل
المساله فعلا يعني معركه باخمت تستاهل كل
هذا الحشد وكل هذه التغطيه ام لا المساله
تتعلق اولا واخيرا بالمكابره من قبل
الطرفين او بالهيبه يعني عن معركه تسمى
الان ام المعارك في في الحرب في اوكرانيا
اذا سمح لنا الوقت طالب يعني المعارك
بالفعل محتدمه في عده محاور عدا عن باقي
وربما تكون اكثر ضراوه من باقمت لكن تسليط
الضوء على هذه المدينه جعلها هي تتصدر
المشهد دائما يعني صباح اليوم هناك اعلان
بتقدم القوات الروسيه عوده نحو كوبيانس
وتبعد الان القوات الروسيه ثلاثه
كيلومترات عن كوبيانس وهي ما زالت تتقدم
للعوده والسيطره على كوبيانس وعلى لمان
محور خاركب هو الاكثر سخونه اليوم والاله
العسكريه الروسيه تضرب عنف الحديث عن 50
الف قذيفه وصاروخ تضرب بشكل يومي في
المنطقه طالب هذا رقم كبير جدا مقارنه مع
200 قذيفه وصاروخ سقطت على المدينه هنا
المئتي قذيفه وصاروخ على المدنيين لكن
الاعمال العسكريه التي يعني
التي الضربات التي تقوم بها الق
الاوكرانيه هي اقل بكثير من كثافه الضربات
التي تقوم بها روسيا عوده الى
بالفعل باخموت مهمه لانها مدينه
استراتيجيه هي تحبس المياه كم تحدثنا عن
نقص المياه ما زلنا نعاني في هذه المدينه
ما زال السكان يعانون من عدم وجود المياه
هناك مدن كبيره خلف مدينه باخمت اذا سيطرت
جيش الروسي على باقي فهذا يعني ان
المواجهه باتت قريبه ما بينهم بين اخر
رائد
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع من دونات مراسل
العربيه
اوضح مسؤولون امريكي ان وزير خارجيه
الولايات المتحده انتوني بلانكن اشترق
لحظات والتقى بنظيره الروسي سيرجيلا بروف
على هامش محادثات مجموعه العشرين في
نيودلهي وقال المسؤول ان بلانكن قابل
لافروف لاول مره منذ بدايه ازمه اوكرانيا
وخلال سيرهما معا اكد ان واشنطن لن تتوقف
عن دعم اوكرانيا وان بلينكن طالب روسيا
بالتراجع عن قرارها بتعليق معاهده ستارت
النوويه الجديده وحث على اطلاق سراح
السجين الامريكي بولا من جهه اشاره
الخارجيه الروسيه الى انه لا يمكن اعتبار
ما جرى مفاوضات رسميه ولم يتم عقد اي لقاء
بينهما
وفي موازاه ذلك فشل اجتماع وزراء خارجيه
مجموعه العشرين في اصدار بيان ختامي موحد
بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سرجي اعلن ان الغرب تجاهل دعوه
بلاده لتضمين بيان مجموعه العشرين ضروره
اجراء تحقيق النزيه في حادثه الانفجارات
على خطي السيل الشمالي رئيس الوزراء
الهندي نارينرا مودي قال ان النظام
العالمي متعدد الاقطاب في ازمه وان
المناقشات تاثرت بالتوترات الجيوسياسيه
فيما جدد المشاركون موقفهم من الصراع في
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك ادانه روسيا وذكر
البيان ان الصراع في اوكرانيا اثر سلبا
على الاقتصاد العالمي
في الوقت نفسه اشار البيان الى وجود اراء
متعدده وتقييمات مختلفه للوضع والعقوبات
وجاء في البيان ان البنده الخاص باوكرانيا
قد تم الاتفاق عليه من قبل جميع الدول
الاعضاء باستثنائي روسيا والصين
وزير الخارجيه الهنديه التي تتولى بلاده
رئاسه قمه مجموعه العشرين قال انه وزراء
خارجيه التكتل توصلوا الى توافق بشان
العديد من القضايا بعد اجتماع ينذله
وركزوا على ما يوحدهم بعد ان هيمنه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه على المناقشه
[موسيقى]
لن يصدر اعلان مشترك من مجموعه العشرين
والغرب هو المسؤول عن ذلك ان بعض الوفود
الغربيه حولت العمل على اجنده مجموعه
العشرين لامر غير جاد عبر تحميلهم روسيا
مسؤوليه اخفاقاتهم الاقتصاديه
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
باريس الان الدكتور محمد سيف الدين وهو
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور محمد
اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه من حيث الشكل هل يمكن
التعويل على هذا اللقاء السريع والجانبي
بين بلينكن
على العكس مجرد ان يتم اللقاء بهذا الشكل
البارد والسريع كما راينا هذا يدل على ان
العلاقات بين البلدين في قاعه تدهور
نعم بدايه يعني التصريحات المتقابله حول
هذا اللقاء السريع بين الرجلين تشير الى
انه اللقاء عابر ولقاء سطحي لا يمكن ان
يدخل في عمق المسائل المختلف حول حولها
وبالتحديد في اوكرانيا الاجواء السابقه
لهذا الاجتماع ولهذا اللقاء تحديدا كانت
تشير الى ان المسافه بعيده جدا بين
الطرفين ولا يمكن يعني اللقاء اللي بضعه
ثواني او دقائق ان يصل او ان يطلق على
الاقل مسارا للحوار بين الطرفين لا تزال
فرص الحوار بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا
في الموضوع الاوكراني تحديدا
متعثره حتى اللحظه ولا يمكن للرهان على
هذا اللقاء هناك مساحه واسعه جدا من
الخلافات وموضوعات كبيره جدا لن تنطلق
يعني اليات الحوار السياسي بشانها في ظل
وجود عدم يعني في ظل انعدام وجود للثقه
بين الطرفين بشكل رئيس والاحداث يعني
المتتابعه تزيد من هذه الهوا بين الطرفين
وتصعب هذا الامر خصوصا مع تداخل ومع دخول
مواقف لاطراف اخرى كالموقف الصيني اليوم
الذي انضم الى جانب الروسي في موضوع
البيان المشترك يعني عدم القبول بصدور
بيان مشترك خصوصا حول القضيه الاوكرانيه
لاحظنا هذه
الحركه من قبل رئيس الوزراء الهندي نارين
دامودي ووزير خارجيته بين جميع الاطراف
طيب في هذه القمه اين تقف نيودلهي تحديدا
مما يجري وهل تلاحظ ان تقترب بسياساتها
الى محور موسكو منه الى محور واشنطن وانه
بشكل او باخر تريد نيودلهي عالما متعدد
الاخطاء الاخطاب كما تريد موسكو ويكون لها
دور فيه
نعم يعني لتفصيل هذا هذا الامر هي تقف على
تقاطعات بين بين المحورين اذا صح التعبير
على المستوى الاقتصادي هي تستفيد بشكل
كبير جدا من الاتفاقيات حول مصادر الطاقه
الروسيه وباسعار مخفضه هي ايضا تعمل وتنشط
ضمن تحالف بريكس او ضمن مجموعه بريكس
وهو هي مجموعه تعبر بشكل علني كل دولها عن
الرغبه بتوليد نظام عالمي جديد متعدد
الاقطاب اذا بالاتجاه الاستراتيجي وبالخط
العام للاستراتيجيه الهنديه نعم هي تريد
عالما متعدد الاقطاب لكن في الناحيه
الامنيه الهند ايضا جزء من تحالف كواد
وهذا التحالف ينشط الان وهو يضم اليها
الولايات المتحده واستراليا وبريطانيا
وبالتالي هي ايضا من جزء من التركيبه
الامنيه
في في الفضاء الهند وهي تريد التعاون
واستمرار التعاون مع الغرب في هذا الشان
هي بالاساس حليفه للولايات المتحده والان
تبحث عن فرص جديده في العالم الذي ترى انه
يتشكل وبالتالي اعتقد ان الهند كان من
مصلحتها ان تصل الى نوع من البيان المشترك
تستطيع ان توفق بين لغه الطرفين لكنها لم
تتمكن من ذلك وموقف الهند صعب في هذه
المساله هي تريد التوفيق بين مسائل في
لحظه متفجره لحظه استراتيجيه لا تقبل
الكثير من اللغه غير غير الحاسمه وباعتقاد
هذا جزء من يعني الصعوبات التي ادت الى
عدم صدور بيان مشترك كنت اسالك ولكن لضيق
الوقت يعني عن موضوع يعني هل واشنطن تحتمل
الان المنطقه الرماديه في مواقف الدول
ولكن نتركه للقاءات اخرى دكتور محمد سيف
الدين الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه من
باريس شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
هذا المشاهدين قبل ان نذهب الى الفاصل اود
ان اشير الى اننا بانتظار مؤتمر صحفي
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
ونظيره الهندي في ختام لقاءات قمه مجموعه
العشرين في نيودله نشرت الخامسه مستمره
فيها بعض الفاصل
نتنياهو يصف المحتشدين حول متجر كانت
زوجته موجوده فيه بالفوضوي
اهلا بكم من جديد يبحثوا الاتحاد الاوروبي
خطه من ثلاثه مسارات لدعم اوكرانيا في
الحرب ضد روسيا وتهدف الخطه الاوروبيه
المقترحه الى التعامل مع حاجات اوكرانيا
من الذخائر عبر مشروع شراء مدته سبع سنوات
سيطلق قريبا تقوده وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه
وذلك لتغطيه حاجات الدول الاعضاء من ذخائر
الاسلحه الصغيره وحتى القذائف من عيار 155
ملي مترا الخطه تنص على تقديم الذخائر الى
اوكرانيا بشكل فوري واعاده ملء مخزونات
الدول الاعضاء ورفع قدرات الانتاج داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي على المدى الطويل
كما تدعو الخطه الاوروبيه الى نقل فوري
للدخائر من المخزونات الحاليه او تلك التي
تم طلبها بالفعل لاوكرانيا
وتاتي هذه الخطه ردا على دعوات من دول
اعضاء لزياده انتاج الذخائر وسط تقديرات
بان روسيا تطلق في اليوم الواحد ما يوازي
ما تنتجه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في شهر
ويقدر بنحو خمسين الف قذيفه في حين ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تستخدم ما يصل الى 7000
قذيفه يوميا وفق مسؤولين اوروبيين
معي من بروكسل لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا
الموضوع مراسل العربيه نور الدين الفريدي
نور اهلا وسهلا بك هل من تفاصيل اضافيه
نور عن هذه الخطه الاوروبيه المقترحه
لزياده الدعم الدفاعي لاوكرانيا وكم ستكون
كلفتها
امام وزراء الدفاع لدول لدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذين سيجتمعون في مطلع الاسبوع
المقبل في السويد هاته الخطه التي وضعتها
المفوضيه الاوروبيه والتي تقترح فيها بصفه
ملحه تزويد اوكرانيا بالقذائف والذخيره
خاصه قذائف المدفعيه من عيار 155
هاتي المشكله التي تواجهها الدول الاعضاء
لانها في حد ذاتها بولندا او فرنسا او
المانيا تواجه نقصا في مخزونها
الاستراتيجيه المفوضيه الاوروبيه تقترح
على الدول الاعضاء ان تضع مليار يورو ينفق
هذا المليار اما مباشره للصناعات العسكريه
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالذخيره من هذه
القذائب او الذخيره بشكل متنوع او ان هذا
المبلغ استخدموا لي
للتعويض لبلد مثل بولندا اذا هذا البلد
قدم ما يكفي من الذخيره او الذخيره
المتوفره لديه الى الى اوكرانيا هذا من
ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه الخطه
تحفز الصناعات العسكريه الاوروبيه بان
هناك مجال لان توسع هذه الصناعات سلاسل
الانتاج كي
تنتج ما تحتاجه جيوش الاوروبيه وبشكل ملح
اوكرانيا من اسلحه وذخيره الملاحظه
الاخيره ان سفير اوروبي قال بشكل واضح ان
العمليه ليست بهاته السهوله بمعنى توفير
الاموال وانتهى الامر
الصناعات العسكريه عندما يطلب منها ان
توسع سلاسل الانتاج معنى ذلك انها هاته
الصناعه ستستثمر مبالغ كبيره وستكون في
حاجه ملحه لعقود في الامد البعيد وبالتالي
الحكومات الاوروبيه هي المدعوه بشكل اساسي
وليس الاتحاد الاوروبي
لابرام هذه العقود لان كل الحكومه لدى
سياستها الدفاع وهنا تكمل ربما واحده من
تعقيدات هذه الاقتراحات هنا السؤال فا
ذا النواه الاوروبيه موافقه على هذه الخطه
وبهذه الميزانيه ام لا يعني
عندما توضع على الطاوله سينقسم ستنقسم دول
الاتحاد كما يعني كنا نشهده في السابق دول
مؤيده وتوافق ودول لا تعترض او تتحفظ
تحديدا هنغاريا وربما صربيا
صحيح طالب في هذه المرحله دول اوروبيه عده
متحفزه على هذا الاقتراح الذي قدم من جانب
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ولكن
بضغط شديد من بولندا ودول البلطيق لماذا
لان هذه الدول قدمت الكثير من مخزونها
لاوكرانيا وهي اليوم تطالب الاتحاد
الاوروبي او تقترح عليه ان يقوم
بعمليات مشتريات مشترك مشتركه بين الدول
الاوروبيه او ان يغطي الاتحاد الاوروبي
هذا النقص في مخزونها البولندي او بالنسبه
لهذه الدوله او تلك وهذه ليست بالضروره
الاولويات كافه ونفسها بالنسبه للدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهي 27 دوله نعم هناك
اتفاق على مستوى العناوين ولكن في
التفاصيل هناك دول عده ربما لا ترى انها
ان هذه هي الاولويه بالنسبه اليها ان
الامر يت علق باولويات السياسات الدفاعيه
ولكل دوله اوروبيه اليوم الصلاحيات
المطلقه في وضع سياساتها الدفاعيه وهذا
الامر ليس بالسياسه الدفاعيه المشتركه حتى
هذا الوقت موجب المعاهده الاوروبيه طيب
سيكتفي بهذا القدر من بروكس المراسل
العربيه نور الدين الفريدي شكرا جزيلا لك
نور على كل هذه المتابعه
قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج انه على الولايات المتحده
وقف مبيعات الاسلحه لتايوان وان تتوقف
ايضا عن خلق عوامل التوتر في المنطقه وذلك
على خلفيه موافقه واشنطن تزويد الجزيره
التايوانيه بصفقه جديده من الاسلحه
تحوط الصين الجانب الامريكي على الالتزام
بمبدا صين واحده وبنود البيانات المشتركه
الصينيه الامريكيه الثلاثه ووقفي مبيعات
الاسلحه لتايوان اضافه لوقف العلاقات
العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان
ووقف خلق عوامل التوتر في مضيق تايوان
ستواصل الصين اتخاذ اجراءات حازمه وقويه
للدفاع بحزم عن سيادتها ومصالحها الامنيه
واود ان اؤكد ان تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من
اراضي الصين فالسبب جذري للتوتر في تايوان
وهو سعي سلطات الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي
للاستقلال والانفصال وكذلك محاوله بعض
الدول استخدام تايوان للسيطره على الصين
حقبه قوانين تنظيم داعش المتطرفه جدا
وحكمه القائم على الترهيب لم تنتهي بعد
العربيه وظن تغطيتها الخاصه تمكنت من دخول
مخيم روج الذي تقيم فيه عوائل عناصر
ومقاتلي داعش الاوروبيين تهديدات مبطنه
وعلانيه قلبت احوال المخيم الذي بدا
بترويج صوره مختلفه للداعشيات اللاتي
خلعنا النقاب لكن الصوره تبدو اسوا واخطر
في مخيم الهول الذي تحولت اقسام منه
لمراكز تعذيب وقتل حيث شهد العام الماضي
مقتل 36 شخصا على ايدي خلايا التنظيم فيما
يبرز دور اهم للداعشيات في تنسيق العمليات
الهجوميه داخل المخيم وخارجه
[موسيقى]
نتفاوض معها للحديث بعد ان تملكها ارتياب
وتردد
قبل سنه فقط كانت داعشيه البلجيكيه وزوجه
احد قاده التنظيم المقتولين في الرقه
تتحدث بثقه مع العربيه عن قصتها كاول
امراه تخلع النقاب في مخيم روش
[موسيقى]
هيئتها تغيرت وقبضه خلايا التنظيم اشتدت
وان امتنعت عن تفسير تحولها هذا
اخر مره
محجبات غير منقبه بس يعني مختلف من بره بس
من جوا ما غير شيء يعني
ماذا تقول ما
بدي نحكي من هذا
كانت رؤيه الكثيرات يتجول دون غطاء راس
ممكنه هناك لكن اليوم ثلاث فقط بقينا دون
حجاب او نقاب ريان واحده منهن تقول انها
تعرضت للتهديد وعرضوا عليها اموالا
[موسيقى]
من مخيم روج انتقل الى الهول الاخطر على
الاطلاق
المواجهه الامنيه مع تنظيم داعش كانت اكثر
حصما ووضوحا لكن مواجهه فكره وارثه معركه
اخرى لم تحسم بعد هنا في مخيم الهول في
الحسكه نسخه متجدده عن تنظيم داعش اصغر
ولكنها ليست اقل تطرفا فلتنظيم هنا ممولون
خلايا التجنيد والتدريب كما له قوانينه
ومحاكم
الحسابات مختلفه هنا وكلها تخضع لقوانين
داعش ترهيب ما لا يلتزم بقوانين التنظيم
وحرق خيانهن او ايذاءهن جسديا هذه الصور
كافيه لشرح ما يحدث اربع نساء احتجزهن
التنظيم وقيدهن بالسلاسل في مركز تعذيب
اقيم سرا داخل مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
لا تتوقف نساء داعش عند التعذيب العام
الماضي شهد المخيم مقتل 36 شخصا بينه
فتاتان مصريتان اكتشفت جثتهما في مجاري
الصرف الصحي حوادث كشفت عن دور المحوري
للنساء داخل خلايا التنظيم بينها تهريب
السلاح
اسمه محمد احمد طلب مني اجيبله من محل ابو
عمار خلاطنا الفواكه
رحت جبت
فتحت ترمز طالع منه المسدس بعد ما طالع
المسدس
[موسيقى]
مكان شخص قال توديني عليه اسمه نور بعد ما
طلعت
تهريب اخذتها المسدس وراحت وديته على
الشخص اسمه نور بعد فتره تم توقيفي من قضى
الجهاز امن العام
لم يقتصر نشاط نساء داعش داخل حدود مخيم
الهول فالتحقيقات كشفت ايضا انهن حلقه وصل
رئيسيه لتنسيق هجمات التنظيم
حمله التنشيط الاخيره حتى الهجوم على سجن
صناعه
الشخص الذي كان يقوم
يعني الاتصال ما بين السجن وخارج السجن
كانت امراه من ضمن المخيم
وضعت في الفتره الاخيره يعتمد على النساء
اكثر يقومون باخفاء الاسلحه الذخيره
او المنشورات
ويتحركون بشكل افضل
حتى عن طريق الانترنت يقوم بالتواصل
ارسلت تعليمات من والى ضعف
في مخيم الهول قصص لا تنتهي هذا قسم
مستحدث يسمونه المنطقه الامنه ينقل اليه
من يثبت ان حياته في خطر بسبب تهديد خلايا
داعش
[موسيقى]
جنب مسجد
الثاني ولمن يضربوا حدا
رصاص نسمع صوت يجيبوني مثلا الفجر مشان
الناس
تنفذ امام المسجد
الخطر يبقى قائما في مخيم تنشط فيه خلايا
داعش وتسعى لكسر قيود الاحتجاز واعاده
تنظيم صفوفها ساره بنعيشوبا العربيه من
شمال شرق سوريا
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قالت قائده
عمليات الجزيره في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
ديلبرين كوباني انهم اغلقوا عددا من
المواقع في مخيم الهول كانت تستخدم
للتعذيب وتدريب اطفال داعش واضافت ان
التنظيم حفر شبكه انفاق قام من خلالها
بعمليات اختطاف من داخل المخيم وخارجه كما
ذكرنا
تم تحديده واغلاق مواقع داعش التي يدربون
فيها الاطفال كما اغلقنا مواقع كانوا
يعذبون فيها بعض سكان المخيم بدا تنظيم
داعش بحفر العديد من الانفاق في المخيم
وكان عناصره يعصبون اعين من يتم اختطافهم
ويبقونهم في الانفاق كان عناصر داعش
يخطفون الناس من داخل المخيم وخارجه
ويعذبونه
توقفت حركه القطارات في تونس بسبب اضراب
عام في القطاع دعت اليه نقابه السكك
الحديد التابعه للاتحاد التونسي للشغل
وارجع مسؤول بنقابه السكك الحديد تنفيذ
هذا الاضراب الى عدم استجابه السلطات
للمطالب وعدم تطبيق اتفاقات سابقه تعود
الى عام 2017
ياتي ذلك قبل يومين من تظاهره كبرى دعى
اليها اتحاد الشغل في العاصمه احتجاجا على
عدم تفعيل الحكومه لاتفاق يتعلق برفع
الاجور
معي من تونس الصحفيه نسرين حمداوي نسرين
اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه اخر المعلومات
المتعلقه بهذه الاضرابات وانعكاسها على
المشهد السياسي في تونس
الجمهوريه هنا في تونس حيث تعطلت الحركه
في 24 ولايه اضافه الى حركه نقل الفوسفاط
في تونس باعتباره الجزء الاكبر منه يتم عن
طريق الشبكه الحديديه في تصنيع العديد
التحركات التي تعيش على واقعها الصحه
السياسيه والساحه النقابيه في تونس
باعتبار ان هنالك عديد الاضرابات التي
تواترت خلال الفتره الاخيره خاصه بعد بعد
تعطر المفاوضات فيما يتعلق بزيادات في
الاجور في عديد القطاعات نذكر من بين
اهمها قطاع النقل هنا في تونس حيث كانت
قطاعات نقابات النقل لوحت باضراب عام برا
وبحرا وجوا لكن تم تاجيل هذا الاضراب
منتصف فيفري الماضي الى منتصف شهر مارس
الحالي حيث من المنتفع يتم تنفيذ اضراب
عام في هذا القطاع يوميه 16 و 17 مارس
الحالي هنالك عديد التحركات الاحتياجيه
ايضا والتجمعات العماليه التي كان دعا لها
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل كان رائع
اكبرها واهمها التجمع العمالي الذي جرى
منذ اسبوعين في صفاقس ايضا ان يتم عقد
اجتماع عمالي ايضا كبير في ساحه محمد علي
بالعاصمه تونس امام المقر المركزي للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل وذلك في ظل تطورات
السياسيه وامنيه كبيره هنا في تونس خاصه
بعد الايقافات التي طالت مجموعه من
القيادات النقابيه من الصف الاول ربما
داخل الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل نعم طيب
بالنسبه الى الملاحقات والاحكام القضائيه
اخر المعلومات عن هذه الملاحقات وعمليات
التوقيف نسرين اذا كان لديك معلومات
بالفعل نسرين انا مضطر لان اتوقف لان
هنالك مؤتمر صحفي للاسف مضطر لانتقل اليه
الى ان يدلهي والمؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي ونظيره الهندي
الاوضاع في الاقتصاد العالمي روسيا والصين
البلدان الوحيدان اللذاني اوضح انهم لن
يوقع على هذا النص في العمل الماضي ثم
تعاشر عضوا في مجموعه العشرين اكدوا انه
من الضروري ان امتثل القانون الدولي في
نظام التعدد
الجهات وهذا عن كافه المبادئ الموضحه في
ميثاق الامم المتحده والالتزام بالقانون
الانساني الدولي
كل عضو في مجموعه العشرين وكل دوله على
الاطلاق تستمر بتحمل تكلفه حرب روسيا
العدائيه هذه الحرب التي يمكنني انها رئيس
بوتين غدا عندما اختار ذلك
الولايات المتحده لم ترغب بهذه الحرب
عملنا جاهدين
الاساسيه التي تؤثر على حياه شعوبنا فحتى
بينما نقف الى جانب اوكرانيا
في هذا العمل نحن عازمنا على العم مع دول
اخرى تقديم الحلول لمواجهه هذه التحديات
المشتركه وهذا ما فعلناه اليوم في مجموعه
العشرين هذه التحديات تشمل ازمه الغذاء
غير المسبوقه في العالم على امران في نفس
الوقت او نوصل الغذاء الى الجيعه الان
كذلك مساعده دول على
تطوير مرونتها وقدرتها الغذائيه المتحده
على الصعيدين لتمويل اكثر من نصف برنامج
الغذاء العالمي 13 نصف مليار دولار
لمكافحه المجاعه في العمل الماضي فقط
والتزمنا باحدى عشر مليار دولار اضافي على
مدى الخمسه لتعزيز مرونه الدول وقدرتها
الغذائيه الدول الافريقيه بالتحديد
اخبرتنا مرارا انا اكثر
المساعدات معجونها هو المساعده البنايه
القدرات المستدامه لاطعام شعوبهم ونحن
نتعاون من اجل تحقيق ذلك الان
والمستويات غير مسبوقه من انعدام الامن
الغذائي المدفوعه بسبب تغير المناخي
وجائحه كوفيد 19 والنزاعات على ان الازمه
تفاقمت بشكل متعمد من قبل رئيس بوتين الذي
قام بتسليح مجاعه العالم او شعوب حول
العالم والفضل جهود
تركيا
من الغذاء يساوي
الاوكرانيه الى العالم اليوم
ومبادره البحر الاسود سوف تنفذ 18 من مارس
فاروس رفضت الالتزام بتجديدها الرساله
انت بعثناها اليوم واضحه وسعوا اتفاقا
مبادره البحر الاسود ومن دون اي تاجيل كما
ناقشنا لمكافحه انتشار والتجاري بالمخدرات
مثلا
في الولايات المتحده لوحدها
اكثر من 70 الف شخصا خلال العام الماضي
وهو المتسبب الرئيسي لقتل الاشخاص من
اعمار 18 الى 40 عاما لا دوله بامكانها
مكافحه هذه مشكله لوحدها علقت سلاسل
الامداد ومنعي الكيماويات غير القانونيه
استخداماتها غير القانونيه
الاجراميه العالميه كلها هذه تحديات تتطلب
جهودا دوليه منسقه ولهذا السبب من المهم
وللمره الاولى فان وزراء مجموعه العشرين
الطالب بتعاون دولي قوي لمكافحه المخدرات
غير القانونيه وكما عبر الوزراء اليوم
فعلينا ابتكر ج مركز لجمع الحكوماتي
والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه والقطاع
الخاص وغيرهم لمعالجه هذه المشكله
هذه مساله
قانون وامنيه ولكن بشكل اساسي صحه عامه
وازمه عالميه بشكل متزايد اليوم ايضا
ناقشنا تحديات اخرى حيث يتوقعوا الشعبه
العالم ان العمل عليها معا مثل معالجه
ازمه المناخ ومساعده مجتمعاتنا اقلمي
والتكيفي مع التغييرات وتعزيز الصحه
العالميه لكي نكون مستعدين لمنعي ومعالجه
الازمات القادمه
نيجيريا جنوب افريقيا والبرازيل
واندونيسيا وهولندا والمكسيكي السعوديه
والارجنتين وبالتاكيد الهند
رئاسه الهند
وزير الخارجيه
اجماعي مجموعه العشرين على مجموعه واسامي
اتفاق التي عكسناها في و واخلاصتنا وهذه
الاولى لوزاره مجموعات العشرين الوزير جيش
أنا نتحدث كثيرا
ودائما نتابع كلامنا ونعمل على تمديد
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه باشكال جاده وقويه
ودعم اجنده الطموحه لمجموعه العشرين
والتي اطلقها الرئيس بعدين في بعضها العام
الماضي
والتزامنا بحقوق الانسان والقيام
الديمقراطيه يوم غد
وانا سنضم الى ضرائنا الياباني واستراليا
في المجموعه الرباعيه لحين ما ياتي لحركه
البضاعه الحره عبر بحارنا وكذلك تعزيز
تعاون نحاول المساعدات الانسانيه واغاثه
الكوارث هذه الاهميه تطرحت مره اخرى
بعد الهسات الارضيه في تركيا وسوريا
تفاعلنا مع المجموعه الرباعيه ومجموعه
العشرين مجرد امثله قليله عن
توثيق الولايات المتحده للتحالفات التي
تعيش قدراتنا على الايفاء لشعوبنا
الى مجموعه الخمس زائد واحد كل ما زادت
هذه الشراكات
وقلنا بتقويتها وتعزيزها كلما تمكنا من
معالج التحديات العابر لحدوث تؤثر على
شعوبنا وتوسيع قدراتنا الامريكيين وتعزيز
امنه وتحقيق مصالحنا
في نيودله واستانا وغيرها هي ان الدول
ترغب بالتشارك مع الولايات المتحده لانها
ترانا دائما موجوده للمشاركه بحلم الشاكل
ورعايه المشترك والاستثمار بتنافساتنا
والوقوفين للدفاع عن القوانين
كل دوله اختيار مسارها بعيدا عن العنف
والعمل القسريه والتهديد
اخيرا تحدث بايجاز مع وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه لايف على هامش اجتماعات مجموعه
العشرين اليوم
قمت بحذفهم على عكس قرارهم غير المسؤول
والعوده لتطبيقي اتفاقيه ستار والتي تضعها
الحدود على الترس النوويه الولايات
المتحده وروسيا الاتحاديه الامثال على
المشتركه مصلحه بلدينا وكذلك ما تتوقعوا
شعوب العالميه منا كقوه نوويه الوزير
الخارجيه بانه مهما حصلت العالم وفي حول
علاقاتنا الولايات المتحده دائما تكون
مستعده للانخراط والعمل على ضبط الاسلحه
كما كما فعلت الولايات المتحده في ذروه
الحرب بارده كما نتحدث عن اعتقال كما طرحت
المساله في عده مناسبات الولايات المتحده
طرحت مقترحا جدا ماسكو عليها ان تقبله نحن
عازمنا لعاده وكل مواطن امريكي اخر اعتقل
بشكل
غير عادل الى وطنه هولندا يهدا الى نبال
الى ان نفعل ذلك واخيرا قتل وزير الخارجيه
وما قاله الكثير من وزراء خارجيه مجموعه
العشرين اليوم انهم حرب
الدبلوماسيه التي تنجم عن سلام عادل
الرئيس
نقاط لهذا السنه الولايات المتحده تقي
مستعدة يعني اوكرانيا عبر الدبلوماسيه
لانهاء الحرب على هذا الاساس الرئيس بوتين
لكن اظهار عدم الاهتمام بين الخيرات
واقعنا لا شيء حتى للتحدث عنهم ما لم
توافقوا اوكرانيا على الواقع الواقع
الاراضي الجديد بينما يضاعفوا اعماله
وهجمته
هو تقديم النتائج حول المشاكل تؤثر حالات
الشعوبنا البلد المضيفه عازمنا
قيادتهم وضيافتهم مواقتهم بالتعبير اعزائي
المشاهدين نكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر
الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتون كان
يتحدث في نيودله على هامش قمه او في ختام
قمه العشرين الخامسه انتهت نلقاكم غدا في
العيد العشرين للعربيه اطيب التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله